Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club and was embarked to cross to Burgundy. That is the Duke of Clarence in Shakespeare's play Richard III. At the time, he is immured in the Tower of London. He's very soon going to be drowned in a butt of marmsy. And in his dream, he has this terrifying vision of being pushed off the ship by his younger brother, Richard the Future, Richard III. Terrible visions as he drowns beneath the sea.
感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。若想收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先听系列节目并加入我们广受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。他踏上了前往勃艮第的旅程。那是莎士ib比亚戏剧《理查三世》中的克拉伦斯公爵。当时，他被囚禁在伦敦塔中。他很快就要在一桶玛姆塞酒中被淹死。在梦中，他看到了一个可怕的幻象，梦见自己被弟弟——未来的理查三世——推下了船。他在海底溺水时，脑海中浮现出可怕的幻象。
But Dominic, we will be coming to Richard III, the myth, the reality, the princes in the tower, all that kind of stuff on a show in the new year. But for now, what I want to focus on in that quote why i chose it is how you can get a ship from england and cross to burgundy because of course burgundy yeah isn't on the coast you can't sail to dijon it's not possible absolutely not so what is going on here um well but it's burgundy it's burgundy isn't it so strange and interesting so i remember first coming across burgundy so i was at my grandfather's house and interesting. So I remember first coming across Burgundy. So I was at my grandfather's house and he had this huge pile of old encyclopedias,
但多米尼克，我们在新的一期节目中会讲到理查三世、神话、现实、塔中王子等诸如此类的内容。但现在，我在这段引言中真正想关注、也是我选择它的原因，是如何从英格兰坐船去勃艮第，因为当然，勃艮第并不在海岸边，你没法乘船去第戎，这是不可能的，绝对不可能。所以这里到底是怎么回事？嗯，不过那是勃艮第，那是勃艮第，不是吗？太神奇、太有趣了。我第一次接触到勃艮第，是在我爷爷家。
kind of leather-bound encyclopedias of history. And I was kind of bored and I was flicking through them. And there was a picture taking up, they were incredibly old, they were kind of late Victorian or Edwardian. There was a picture taking up the whole page and engraving. And it was an engraving of this meeting on a bridge between, who is it?
那种皮面装帧的历史百科全书。我当时有点无聊，就随手翻看。里面有一张占据了整页的插图，是一幅版画。那是关于一座桥上的一场会面，是谁和谁来着？
John the Fearless and his kind of French rival, and they're having a parley, and John the Fearless is about to be butchered to death. And I thought, oh my God, this is amazing. Even at the age of sort of nine or 10, I could see this was this incredible Game of Thrones-style story, this great soap opera. I think before we get into that,
无畏的约翰和他法国的对手，他们正在进行谈判，而无畏的约翰即将被残忍杀害。我想，哦天哪，这太棒了。哪怕在九十岁左右的年纪，我也能看出这是一个极其精彩的“权力的游戏”式的故事，是一部伟大的肥皂剧。我想在我们深入探讨之前，
we should explain what we're talking about. But that's the thing, I didn't know when I read it what Burgundy was. Okay, so the late 14th, 15th century, Burgundy is not just the French region of Burgundy now. No. But this great agglomeration of territories that goes up to the North Sea and incorporates much of what's now Belgium, Holland, the Netherlands, all that. And it's one of the great what-ifs of history because it's an incredible process of state building that could well have seen a new kingdom emerge between- Yeah, and it's a tragedy for the world that Burgundy doesn't exist as a country, don't you?
我们应该先解释一下我们在谈论什么。但问题就在于，我当时读的时候并不知道勃艮第是什么。好吧，在14世纪末、15世纪，勃艮第不仅仅是现在法国的勃艮第地区。不。而是一个庞大的领地集合体，一直延伸到北海，吞并了如今的大部分比利时、荷兰，以及诸如此类的地方。这是历史上的伟大“假设”之一，因为它是一次不可思议的国家建设进程，很有可能会催生出一个全新的王国——对啊，而且勃艮第作为一个国家不复存在，这可以说是世界的悲剧，你不觉得吗？
And I guess the fact that Shakespeare is talking, so it collapses at the end of the 15th century, but still at the end of the 16th century, Shakespeare is talking about it. So it's there in Richard III, in King Lear, Cordelia has the choice between, you know, the kings of France and the kings of waterish Burgundy. And it's waterish because, you know, it's the canals, the dikes of the low country so it's an incredible story a story that is i think not widely known in england but it should be because the english are key players in this drama together with the french and the burgundians um and it's the subject of a recently published book translated from the flemish that you absolutely loved didn't you made it one of your history books of the year uh bart van louw, if I'm pronouncing that correctly, The Burgundians. A vanished empire. And do you know what, Tom?
我想莎士比亚所提到的——它在15世纪末崩溃了，但直到16世纪末，莎士比亚仍然在谈论它。所以它存在于《理查三世》中，在《李尔王》中，科迪莉亚面临着这样的选择：法国国王和多水的勃艮第国王。之所以说是多水的，因为那是低地国家的运河和堤防。所以这是一个不可思议的故事，一个在英格兰或许不太为人所知、但却应该广为人知的故事，因为英国人是这场戏剧的关键参与者，法国人和勃艮第人也是如此。嗯，这是一本最近出版的、从佛兰芒语翻译过来的书的主题，你绝对爱不释手，对吧？你把它列为了你年度历史图书之一。巴特·范·洛（Bart van Loo），如果我没发错音的话，《勃艮第人：一个消逝的帝国》。你知道吗，汤姆？
A very exciting moment for the podcast. We have Bart van Leeuw here with us. Well, who'd have thought it? Hello. What a turn up for the books. Hello, Bart. Yes, I'm talking to you from the old county of Flanders, not far away from the Battle of Rozebeck, not far from Ypres and Bruges.
对这个播客来说，这是一个非常激动人心的时刻。我们把巴特·范·洛请到了现场。好吧，谁能想到呢？你好。真是个意外之喜。你好，巴特。是的，我正在古老的法兰德斯伯国与你们对话，离罗斯贝克战役不远，离伊珀尔和布鲁日也不远。
So it's the right place to talk to you about Burgundy in Flanders. Well, Bart, it's brilliant to have you on because I think you are our first Belgian guest. Our first Burgundian guest. But that's how we prefer to think of you, as a Burgundian. So could we kick off with a question from Barry Grogan, very much a friend of the show, who asked very simply, who and what are the Dukes of Burgundy? I have vague memories of them perhaps being involved in the capture of Joan of Arc. And I mean, that's right, isn't it? We'll come to Joan of Arc perhaps later. But just to begin with, who are the Dukes of Burgundy? How is it that they're
所以，这是跟你们聊法兰德斯和勃艮第的绝佳地点。太好了，巴特，你能来真是太棒了，因为我想你是我们的第一位比利时嘉宾。我们的第一位勃艮第嘉宾。但我们更愿意这样看待你，把你当成一个勃艮第人。那么，我们能以巴里·格罗根（节目老朋友）的一个问题作为开端吗？他非常简单地问道：勃艮第公爵究竟是谁，又是什么？我隐约记得他们可能参与了捕获圣女贞德的行动。我的意思是，这没错，对吧？我们可能稍后会谈到圣女贞德。但首先，勃艮第公爵到底是谁？他们是怎么
able to almost to construct this new realm? Yes. Maybe let's start very from the basics. Let's take a look at the map of Europe at the end of the Middle Ages. And on the continent, we see two powers. We see the French kingdom and we see the Holy Roman Empire. And between the two, there's a border. Likely, it's going to rest forever.
几乎能够构建出这个新王国的？是的。也许我们还是从最基础的开始吧。让我们看看中世纪末期的欧洲地图。在欧洲大陆上，我们看到两个强权。我们看到法兰尼斯王国，也看到神圣罗马帝国。而这两者之间有一条边界。看起来，它将永远存在下去。
And we in the north we exist we have flanders we have brabant we have zealand and holland but either we belong to france or either we belong to say germany the holy roman empire and then nobody saw it coming in the 14th 15th century we see um we see come there is there is the the, how do you say it, the apparition of a new state between those two superpowers. And that is the fruit of the labor of those forgotten dukes of Burgundy. And it's incredible, just to put it in another way. I am a 40-year-old Dutch-speaking Belgian. I am unexplicable without the dukes of Burgundy because what they created is the Low Countries,
而在北方，我们有法兰德斯，我们有布拉班特，我们有泽兰和荷兰，但我们要么属于法国，要么属于德国（神圣罗马帝国）。然后，在14、15世纪，谁也没有预料到，我们看到……我们看到……怎么说呢，这两个超级大国之间崛起了一个新的国家。这就是那些被遗忘的勃艮第公爵们辛勤劳动的果实。这太不可思议了，换一种方式来说：我是一个40岁、说荷兰语的比利时人。如果不提勃艮第公爵，我的存在就无法解释，因为他们创造了低地国家，
the Nederlanden. It's a cradle of what become further on Belgium and the Netherlands. And famously Belgians. You know, Belgium is divided between Flemish speakers and French speakers. And that, I guess, also is a legacy of... Yes, and of course it is.
即荷兰（Nederlanden）。它是后来比利时和荷兰的摇篮。众所周知，比利时人……你知道的，比利时分为说佛兰芒语的和说法语的。我想这也是……是的，当然是的，这也是一种遗产。
And they have been overlooked in national history, in Belgium, in Holland, in France, in England. The Daily Telegraph, they put a telegraph, they put a title on the review of my book. I love the title. We forgot the Burgundians! Exclamation mark. Bart, do you know, you'll be very pleased to know this,
而且他们在国家历史中被忽视了——在比利时、在荷兰、在法国、在英国。《每日电讯报》给我的书写了一篇书评，我非常喜欢那个标题。我们忘记了勃艮第人！感叹号。巴特，你知道吗，你听到这个一定会很高兴，
I studied them at school. Did you? Yeah, I did. At school? I mark. But Bart, do you know, you'll be very pleased to know this, I studied them at school. Did you? Yeah, I did. At school? I did. But at what age? 17 to 18. At A-level, Tom?
我在学校里学过他们。是吗？对，我学过。在学校里？我……等等。但巴特，你知道吗，你听到这个一定会很高兴，我在学校里学过他们。是吗？对，我学过。在学校里？我学过。但那是几岁的时候？17到18岁。在A-level阶段吗，汤姆？
17 to 18? Yeah, I did them at A-level. Wow. So you know all about this. I know all about this. I know all about this. I've been going through my A-level notes. You don't know as much as Bart.
17到18岁？对，我在A-level学过他们。哇。所以你对这个了如指掌。我对这个了如指掌。我对这个了如指掌。我一直在翻看我的A-level笔记。你可没有巴特知道得那么多。
I mean, you haven't written a book about it. No, that's possibly true. I mean, Bart should't written a book about it. No, that's possibly true. I mean, Bart should give you a quiz or something. So, yes, yes, I will ask him some questions. So, Tom, you will agree that... No! No! I don't want a quiz. This is like this awful kind of flashback where you have to go and answer an essay on Hamlet and you haven't done
我的意思是，你又没写过关于这的书。不，这大概是真的。我是说，巴特应该给你出个测验什么的。所以，是的，是的，我会问他一些问题。所以，汤姆，你会同意……不！不！我不要测验。这就像那种可怕的闪回，你得去回答一篇关于《哈姆雷特》的论文，而你根本还没复习。
the revision. Yes, yes. Oh, that's good. It's good. I like that. But you will agree, Tom, that this history of geopolitical evolution of the highest order, in the same time, it's also a Game of Thrones story. It's about banquet stakes and battles and murders and adultery and bastards. And the only thing it's schizophrenic kings, aggressive dukes go on. And the only thing that is missing are dragons. But for a good reason, because this is Game of Thrones that really happened.
好极了，好极了。我喜欢这样。但你总会同意的，汤姆，这段最高级别的地缘政治演变史，同时也是一个“权力的游戏”式的故事。它关乎宴会、阴谋、战争、谋杀、通奸和私生子。这里有精神错乱的国王、好斗的公爵，唯一的区别是里面没有龙。但这是有充分理由的，因为这就是真实发生的“权力的游戏”。
But you say Game of Thrones, I mean, there are dwarves. Yes, on very own dwarves. There are giants. There are kind of incredible feasts. There are chivalric orders. I mean, and it has to be said that there are basically four dukes. They all have brilliant kind of soubriquets, and they're all massive lads i mean there is no
但你说是“权力的游戏”，我是说，这里面有侏儒。是的，属于他们自己的侏儒。有巨人。有难以置信的盛宴。有骑士团。我的意思是，必须指出的是，这里基本上有四位公爵。他们都有极其拉风的绰号，而且个个都是猛男。这一点毋庸置疑。
getting away from it so let's start with the first one let's go to the very beginning so bart i think in your book you kick off with the battle of a great moment in english history the battle of poitiers where we wipe the floor with the french why does why does that matter for burgundy this is 100 years war isn't it? We should just say. It's the Hundred Years' War. Edward III has claimed the English throne and his son Edward the Black Prince. Yes, it's the Hundred Years' War and normally every Englishman should know about it.
所以让我们从第一位开始，回到最初。巴特，我想在你的书里，你开篇就提到了普瓦捷战役——英国历史上高光的一刻，我们在那儿把法国人打得落花流水。为什么这对勃艮第很重要？这是百年战争，对吧？我们应该说明一下。这是百年战争。爱德华三世宣称拥有英格兰王位，还有他的儿子黑太子爱德华。是的，这是百年战争，正常情况下每个英国人都应该知道。
Do you have a stopwatch? Maybe I can try to explain the Hundred Years' War in less than one minute. Go for it. In France, the stock of royal successor was exhausted. There was only left a woman, but she was married to the king of England, who became just because he was sleeping in the right bed with the right woman,
你有秒表吗？也许我可以试着用不到一分钟的时间解释百年战争。来吧。在法国，皇位继承人的库存耗尽了。只剩下一个女人，但她嫁给了英格兰国王，而后者仅仅因为睡在正确的床上、娶了正确的女人，
king of France. And the French didn't like that. So they invented new game rules. The power cannot be given to a woman. And that the English didn't like. And they invaded France, conquered one thirdthird, two-thirds, almost the whole kingdom. How many seconds? That was about 30.
就成了法兰克国王。法国人不喜欢这样。于是他们发明了新的游戏规则：权力不能交给女人。英国人不喜欢这样。于是他们入侵法国，征服了三分之一、三分之二，几乎整个王国。用了多少秒？大概30秒。
I mean, you've got extra time. You do what you like. Let's go. Because we talk about 100 years, but at that moment, people didn't were aware of that. It's not that some Englishman was saying oh it's year 17 we we have 83 years to come no and and at the end it it lasted 116 year but nobody dared to call this war the 116 years war because it's not so sexy so we are on that battle of poitiers in 1356 in france they have completely forgotten about it
我的意思是，你还有富余时间。你想怎么用都行。继续。因为我们谈论的是100年，但在当时，人们并没有意识到这一点。并不是说某个英国人会说“哦，现在是第17年，我们还有83年要过”，不，而且最后它持续了116年，但没有人敢把这场战争叫做“116年战争”，因为这不够性感。所以我们回到了1356年的普瓦捷战役，在法国，他们已经完全把它忘得精光了，
because, of course, you won. It was Chrissy. You have Agincourt. You have Poitiers. In France, it's overshadowed by another battle, the Battle of Poitiers. That's my first quiz question. Which Battle of Poitiers they talk about in France?
因为，当然了，你们赢了。那是克雷西。你们有阿金库尔。你们有普瓦捷。但在法国，它被另一场战役掩盖了——普瓦捷战役。这是我的第一个测验问题：他们在法国说的是哪一场普瓦捷战役？
Oh, Charles Martel. Of course, 732. They talk about that all the time. But we are in 1356 and John the Good, I don't know why they called him John the Good because he was a complete mess. But he is too enthusiastic and he's there with the best trained army of Europe.
哦，查理·马特。当然，732年。他们一直在谈论那个。但我们现在在1356年，“好人”约翰——我不知道为什么他们叫他“好人”，因为他简直是个彻头彻尾的灾难。但他过于狂热，带着欧洲训练有素的军队来到了那里。
He cannot lose this battle. But at the end, we see the English, the half of his army is deserting. So the English, they are fighting themselves away to John the Good. They can ask a lot of money if they get him. And then, very important, it is the first moment of glory of our first founding father, Philip the Bold. And Philip the Bold is just a little guy.
他不可能输掉这场战役。但到最后，我们看到英国人，他的一半军队在逃跑。所以英国人一路杀向“好人”约翰。如果能抓住他，他们就能勒索到一大笔钱。然后，非常重要的一点，这是我们第一位国父——勇敢的菲利普——高光时刻的开始。而勇敢的菲利普当时只是个小家伙。
He has 14 years, just about 13, 14 years old. And he's transforming himself into a military GPS. He's saying to his father, look out from the right, look out, beware on the left. And so he's able to kill some English soldiers. But it's impossible. At the end, feet were being broken, arms chopped off, entrails spilling from open bellies. The group around the French king was shrinking by the minute. And so at the end, he has to surrender to, can I say so, perfid Albion, as they would say later on.
他只有14岁，大概13、14岁。他把自己变成了一个军事GPS。他对他父亲喊道：“当心右翼！当心！左翼注意！”于是他成功杀死了一些英国士兵。但这无济于事。最后，骨头碎裂，手臂被砍断，内脏从开膛破肚中流出。法国国王周围的人数每分钟都在减少。所以最终，他不得不向——我能这么说吗——后来人们所说的“背信弃义的阿尔比恩”投降。
You can't say that on this podcast. No, you can't say that on this podcast. Yes, I don't know. But you were on a French podcast yesterday, and you mustn't get them muddled. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Were you saying that kind of stuff on the French podcast that you were on a French podcast yesterday, and you mustn't get them muddled. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Were you saying that kind of stuff on the French podcast that you went on? Yes, but it's another.
你不能在这个播客里这么说。不，你不能在这个播客里这么说。是的，我不知道。但你昨天刚上过一个法国播客，你可别把它们搞混了。对，对，对。你在那个法国播客里也说过这种话吗？你昨天上过一个法国播客，你可别把它们搞混了。对，对，对。你在那个你去过的法国播客里也说过这种话吗？是的，不过那是另一个。
We had quite laughs. We are just starting, and we laughed because in France, I'm a Francophile. I'm known as a Francophile. But when you are talking on France Culture, nobody is laughing. They're very serious. So I was there just to make also, we can be enthusiastic about history. It's just very important to learn things
我们笑得很开心。我们刚开始聊就笑了，因为在法国，我是个亲法派。我以亲法派著称。但当你在“法国文化电台”讲话时，没有人会笑。他们非常严肃。所以我在那儿也是为了表明，我们可以对历史充满热情。边学习知识边开怀大笑，这非常重要。
and laugh at the same time. But that's not very French. So I understand it is very English. When I see that very famous journalists and writers are writing about my book, not just little articles, but all pages. So you see that English, they like the narrative history. So I'm becoming a little bit Anglophile. I'm so glad to hear that.
但那不太“法式”。所以我理解这非常“英式”。当我看到那些著名的记者和作家在撰写关于我的书的评论时，不仅是小文章，而是整页整页的篇幅。所以你看，英国人喜欢叙事历史。所以我正在变得有点亲英。我很高兴听到这个。
But also, Bart, presumably the reason the French went laughing was because they'd been humiliated because their king had been captured, taken to the Tower of London, and they had to pay an absolutely extortionate ransom. But as you say, so Philip, who comes, he gets given the name the Bold. The Bold. Philip the Bold. The journalist. His bravery. The chroniclers in French, they searched something positive. So they named him Philip the Bold because he saved his father on the battlefield. But then he's still the Benjamin of the French king.
不过，巴特，法国人之所以没笑，大概是因为他们受到了羞辱，因为他们的国王被俘虏、带到了伦敦塔，他们还不得不支付一笔极其敲诈勒索的赎金。但正如你所说，菲利普获得了一个称号——勇敢的。勇敢的。勇敢的菲利普。记者。他的勇敢。法国的编年史家们试图寻找一些积极的东西。所以他们称他为“勇敢的菲利普”，因为他在战场上救了他的父亲。但当时他仍然是法国国王的小儿子。
How does he get burgundy and that he owes to the plague it is the then the the the duke of burgundy is also called philip it's i'm so sorry everybody they're all called philip it's a lot of complicated but we can forget about him very quickly because he's killed by the plague. And he has no sons, no daughters. So the Duke of the Duchy of Burgundy comes back to the crown of France. And John the Good says, now I can thank my son because he saved me at the battlefield of Poitiers. And he says, here, there you go, Burgundy. And so you see that our first founding father is really a man of his time.
他是怎么得到勃艮第的呢？这要归咎于瘟疫。当时，勃艮第公爵也叫菲利普——非常抱歉，各位，他们都叫菲利普，这太复杂了，但我们可以很快忘掉他，因为他死于瘟疫。他没有儿子，也没有女儿。所以勃艮第公国回到了法兰西王室手中。“好人”约翰说，现在我可以感谢我的儿子了，因为他在普瓦捷战场上救了我。他说：“拿去吧，勃艮第归你了。”所以你看，我们的第一位国父真的是一个时代的人。
His name, he owes it to the Hundred Years' War and his land to the plague. So, Bart, let me just interrupt you. Yes. He has been given the Duchy of Burgundy. Yes. So the Duchy of Burgundy is basically Dijon and the area around Dijon. Dijon, Beaune, Autun. It's the wine area. So in England, we would know that largely because of wine. I'm going to jump on that because when you say Burgundy in France,
他的名字得益于百年战争，而他的土地则归功于瘟疫。所以，巴特，请允许我打断你一下。是的。他被授予了勃艮第公国。是的。所以勃艮第公国基本上就是第戎以及第戎周边地区。第戎、博讷、欧坦。那是葡萄酒产区。所以在英格兰，我们主要因为葡萄酒而知道它。我要借题发挥一下，因为当你在法国、比利时甚至英格兰说起勃艮第时，他们想到的都是葡萄酒，还有芥末——第戎芥末。好吧，让我们深入探讨一下，因为正是勇敢的菲利普本人，
in Belgium, even in England, they think wine and eventually mustard, Moutarde de Dijon. Well, let's look into that because it was Philip the Bold himself. He is banning the Gamay grape to the south. It becomes the grape of Beaujolais. And he's instoring the Pinot Noir, the quintessential grape of Burgundy. And he does that in 1395 with his big Ordonnance du Vin. And then later on, at the same moment, he is improving the production of making mustard. I'm not going into details. So if you think Burgundy, you think wine, you think mustard, you should think Philip the Bolt.
他将佳美葡萄驱逐到南方。它成为了博若莱的葡萄。他引入了黑皮诺，也就是勃艮第最具代表性的葡萄品种。他在1395年通过他的重大《葡萄酒法令》（Ordonnance du Vin）做到了这一点。然后，在同一时期，他改进了芥末的生产工艺。我就不展开细讲了。所以，如果你想到勃艮第，你想到葡萄酒，你想到芥末，你就应该想到勇敢的菲利普。
Okay, that's a lesson to our listeners there. And Bart, I have to say that that is part of what I love about this whole theme, is that, as you say, I mean, there's a lot of fighting, of murdering, of backstabbing and all that kind of stuff, but there is just so much food and drinks and feasting. It's just great. So he gets the title of Duke of Burgundy. Yes. How then does he get his hands on the Lowlands? Yeah, because he's going to marry Margaret of Flanders. And she's the richest heiress of Europe.
好的，这是给我们听众的一课。巴特，我不得不说，这也是我喜欢这个宏大主题的原因之一。正如你所说，这里面有很多战斗、谋杀、背后捅刀子之类的事情，但同时也有那么多的食物、美酒和盛宴。真是太棒了。所以他获得了勃艮第公爵的头衔。是的。那么，他是如何将低地国家收入囊中的呢？是的，因为他将迎娶法兰德斯的玛格丽特。她是欧洲最富有的女继承人。
And it's incredible because it was also the English king who wanted to marry Flanders. But the English kings, they always win on the battlefield. But when it comes to marrying... The marriage bed. The bedchamber. Then the Burgundians, they win all the time and so it's it's the 19th of june 1369 and philip the bold the mighty duke of burgundy is coming to gant is is going to marry the richest heiress of um of europe and we know that just before his wedding
这太不可思议了，因为当时英国国王也想娶法兰德斯。但英国国王们总是能在战场上获胜，可当谈到结婚时……婚床。洞房花烛夜。勃艮第人总是能赢，所以那是1369年6月19日，伟大的勃艮第公爵勇敢的菲利普来到根特，准备迎娶欧洲最富有的女继承人。我们知道，就在他的婚礼前夕，
he's taking a bath and we know that he sprinkled himself with violet perfume. I like those details. He looks through the window and see how the most illiterate counts and dukes of Europe strut across the church square like peacocks. But he knows that a few minutes later when he's going down, he will show up as the best dressed man in Europe
他洗了个澡，而且我们知道他在身上洒满了紫罗兰香水。我喜欢这些细节。他透过窗户看着欧洲那些目不识丁的伯爵和公爵们如何像孔雀一样在教堂广场上大摇大摆。但他知道，几分钟后当他走下去时，他将成为欧洲穿着最得体的人，
and all the best smelling compared to him and become great crows. So I like to describe that. Flanders is very important. It's like the... You say in your book, you say the Silicon Valley of the Middle Ages. Yes, it is that. It's the
闻起来也是最香的，而相比之下，那些人不过是些大乌鸦。我喜欢这样描述。法兰德斯非常重要。它就像是……你在书里说过，它是中世纪的硅谷。是的，确实如此。它是
richest country of Europe. What is it that makes it so rich and advanced? Because it's the woodcloth industry, of course. There we get England peaking, of course, and the wool of England, very important. And there is a demographic boom. I just give some figures. In about 1300, there are in Ypres,
欧洲最富有的国家。是什么让它如此富有和先进？因为木织物工业，当然了。这里有英国的鼎盛期，当然还有英国的羊毛，非常重要。而且这里发生了人口爆炸。我只举一些数据。大约在1300年，在伊珀尔——
20 kilometers from where I live, there are 30,000 people living there. In Bruges, 45,000. In Ghent, almost 70,000. And just to make it very clear, at the same moment in Amsterdam, there are only just 1,000 people living in Amsterdam. So I like a lot telling this. So the only city in Northern Europe that's larger is Paris.
离我住的地方20公里——有3万人口。在布鲁日有4.5万人。在根特，将近7万人。为了说得更明白一点，在同一时期，阿姆斯特丹只有区区1000人口。所以我很喜欢讲这个。所以，北欧唯一比它大的城市只有巴黎。
I mean, these are larger than London. Yes, but it's only Paris. The rest of France is empty. I mean, these are larger than London. Yes, but it's only Paris. The rest of France is empty. And what do we have? Ghent, Bruges and Ypres. It's just one day walking away one city from the other. So it's together.
我的意思是，这些城市比伦敦还要大。是的，但只有巴黎。法国其他地方都是空荡荡的。我的意思是，这些城市比伦敦还要大。是的，但只有巴黎。法国其他地方都是空荡荡的。我们有什么？根特、布鲁日和伊珀尔。它们彼此相距只有一天的步行路程。所以加在一起，
It's bigger than Paris. But it's beyond that. They've got all kinds of financial innovations. They have the origins of what in French they call the bourse. So basically they're trading stocks. They have guilds. They have the arts. They're inventing oil painting, aren't they?
它比巴黎还要大。但不仅于此。他们拥有各种金融创新。他们拥有法国人所说的“bourse（证券交易所）”的起源。基本上他们在交易股票。他们有行会。他们有艺术。他们发明了油画，不是吗？
Yes, we can discuss a long time. We should talk about Jan van Eyck at some point, I think. But it is so that there is a lot of money in Flanders, and Philip the Bold, he will do amazing stuff with that. To begin with, he will build a monastery near Dijon called Chamolle. And now it's getting very interesting because to decorate Chamolle, he's inviting the biggest artist from the north to Dijon. Let's talk about sculptor Klaus Sluiter from Harlem. Let's talk about a painter called Johan Malwaal. He's the first...
是的，我们可以讨论很久。我想我们迟早得谈谈扬·凡·艾克。但事实是，法兰德斯有大量的资金，而勇敢的菲利普将用这些资金做出惊人的事情。首先，他将在第戎附近建造一座名为尚莫勒（Chamolle）的修道院。现在事情变得非常有趣了，为了装饰尚莫勒，他邀请了北方最大的艺术家来到第戎。让我们谈谈来自哈勒姆的雕塑家克劳斯·斯吕特（Klaus Sluiter）。让我们谈谈一位名叫约翰·马尔瓦尔（Johan Malwaal）的画家。他是第一位……
Malwaal. Malwaal. Malwaal. That's a silly name. It's not my fault he's called this way. Sorry, it just sounds... Yes. Yes, I was the first king of England called.
马尔瓦尔。马尔瓦尔。马尔瓦尔。真是个傻气的名字。他叫这个名字又不是我的错。抱歉，听起来……对。是的，我是第一位被称为……的英格兰国王。
It was a strange name. If you talk about... Athelstan. Athelstan, nothing wrong with that. It's a very sensible name. That's an excellent name. What are you talking about? Athel-weird, perhaps.
这是一个奇怪的名字。如果你说的是……埃塞尔斯坦。埃塞尔斯坦，这没什么毛病。这是一个非常理智的名字。这是一个极好的名字。你在说什么呢？埃塞尔威德（Athel-weird），也许吧。
We've got to stop having these Belgians on our podcast, Tom. Insulting our kings. But those... Johan Malwaal, he's the first Holland painter we've known, thanks to the... How do you say it, the accountancy of the Dukes of Burgundy. There is the painter Melchior Broederland,
我们得停止在播客里请这些比利时人了，汤姆。他们老是侮辱我们的国王。但那些……约翰·马尔瓦尔，他是我们所知的最早的荷兰画家，多亏了……怎么说呢，勃艮第公爵的账簿。还有画家梅尔基奥尔·布罗德兰（Melchior Broederland），
he's the first Flemish painter we know by name. And now it's very interesting because I say the first, yes, two times I say the first. We are witnessing the birth of art history of Belgium and of and of the low countries but not and that's very interesting in the low countries in dijon and that's very interesting so we have all those artists they're coming from the north from holland from zealand from uh brabant from flams they're coming to dijon where they are talking their um their own Dutch, middle Dutch, their own middle French. And they're talking and working with each other in that famous place called Chamonix.
他是我们所知的最早留有姓名的佛兰芒画家。现在这很有趣，因为我说“最早”，对，我说了两次“最早”。我们正在见证比利时和低地国家艺术史的诞生。而且——这非常有趣——不是在低地国家，而是在第戎。这太有趣了。所以我们拥有所有这些艺术家，他们来自北方，来自荷兰、泽兰、布拉班特、法兰德斯，他们来到第戎，在那里说着他们自己的荷兰语、中古荷兰语、他们自己的中古法语。他们在那座著名的尚莫勒修道院里互相交流、共同工作。
And there we see for the first time in history, life in action, the concept of the Low Countries. We, dear Dominique, dear Tom, we are born in fine arts, in the arts. We are born in fine arts. And this is such a stimulating idea, provocative idea, that I would really completely understand that now you all heave a sigh of arousal. Arousal. The very thought, arousal of that thought, becauseal of the fact of that thought because it's incredible in our history art precedes politics isn't that a great idea of origin in england cannot say that uh well no we can't i'm very i'm very happy very happy to concede that clearly the low countries in this period,
我们在历史上第一次看到，生活在行动中，低地这一概念的诞生。亲爱的多米尼克，亲爱的汤姆，我们在美术、在艺术中诞生。我们在美术中诞生。这是一个如此具有启发性、挑衅性的想法，以至于我完全能够理解，现在你们所有人都在发出激动的叹息。激动。一想到这个，就会为之激动——因为在我们的历史中，艺术先于政治，难道这不是一个伟大的起源构想吗？在英格兰，人们可不敢这么说——好吧，不，我们不敢。我非常、非常高兴地承认，显然，这一时期的低地国家，
I mean, it's the great motor of civilization, of finance, of everything. Capitalism. Capitalism, of everything that is kind of going to turbocharge the early modern period in a way. And the Dukes of Burgundy are presiding over this. So Philip the Bold, I mean, he's become the most powerful figure, presumably in France, because John the Good dies. You have Charles V and you have Charles VI who goes mad. He thinks he's made of glass, doesn't he? Yes.
我的意思是，它是文明、金融、一切事物的巨大发动机。资本主义。资本主义，所有将以某种方式为近代早期注入强劲动力的东西。而勃艮第公爵们正统领着这一切。所以勇敢的菲利普，我的意思是，他已经成为了法国最具权势的人物，因为“好人”约翰去世了。你有了查理五世，还有发疯的查理六世。他以为自己是玻璃做的，对吧？是的。
And Philip basically becomes the regent. Yes, he is the king. You can say he's the king. He's the king. He's the regent. But he gets all the power and he can use the money of Flanders and the money of France. So he can do whatever he wants. But Charles VI has a brother, Louis, the Duke of Orléans.
菲利普基本上成了摄政王。是的，他就是国王。你可以说他就是国王。他就是国王。他是摄政王。但他掌握了所有的权力，他可以使用法兰德斯的资金和法国的资金。所以他可以为所欲为。但查理六世有一个弟弟，奥尔良公爵路易。
Yes. And this is seeding a problem, isn't it? Yes, because now, yes, that's the problem. It's because after Philip the Bold, we should say, when he dies, there is the sculptor that I named a few minutes ago, Klaus Schluter, who will carve in alabaster, he will carve some little figures, those famous pleurons who will carry the grave of Philip the Bolt. And dear everybody who is listening now, please, when we are done,
是的。这埋下了隐患，不是吗？是的，因为现在，是的，这就是问题所在。因为在勇敢的菲利普死后，正如我几分钟前提到的那位雕塑家克劳斯·斯吕特，他将用雪花石膏雕刻一些小雕像——那些著名的哀悼者，他们将抬着勇敢的菲利普的灵柩。所有正在收听的听众朋友们，求求你们了，等我们节目结束时，
take a ticket to Burgundy and go to the Museum of Fine Arts and kneel before those little figurines of alabaster. And you will see how those figures, they are coming to life. Before your eyes, you will feel how the alabaster begins to breathe. We will try and put that on the tweet that we put out. Yes, you should go there.
买张去勃艮第的票，去美术博物馆，在那些雪花石膏小雕像前下跪吧。你会看到这些雕像如何复活。在你的眼前，你会感觉到雪花石膏开始呼吸。我们会试着把它发到推特上。是的，你们应该去看看。
But then, yeah, he's dead. John the Fearless, his son is coming on, but he's just the grandson of the king. He's not the son anymore. So he's far away from real power. And the real power now is going to the brother of the mad king, Louis of Orléans, and he's going to kill him to be in power again. And that's what's happening in 1407. So John organises that, doesn't he?
但随后，是的，他死了。无畏的约翰，他的儿子继位了，但他只是国王的孙子。他不再是儿子了。所以他离真正的权力很远。而真正的权力现在落在了疯王弟弟、奥尔良公爵路易的手中，为了重新掌权，约翰要杀了他。这就是1407年发生的事情。所以约翰策划了这件事，对吧？
He organises a sort of series of hitmen. They attack Louis with axes, is that right? But isn't there also a detail, Bart, that John thinks that Louis of Orléans is sleeping with his wife? Isn't that right? Yes, but that's a rumour that is running. We don't know if it's right, but that's very interesting because it makes those dukes and those kings,
他组织了一帮刺客。他们用斧头袭击了路易，是这样吗？但巴特，还有一个细节，是不是约翰认为路易·奥尔良在和他的妻子睡觉？是这样吗？是的，不过这只是个传闻。我们不知道是不是真的，但这非常有趣，因为它让这些公爵、这些国王，
and the first times those dukes, people of flesh and blood. There are a lot of women in this story. There's a lot of adultery. There's a lot of bastards. And we like that. Of course, we like that. We understand because they were traveling a lot. Of course, there was a lot of bastards.
历史上第一次变成了有血有肉的人。这个故事里有很多女性。有很多通奸。有很多私生子。我们喜欢这样。当然，我们喜欢。我们理解，因为他们经常旅行。当然会有很多私生子。
They were traveling all the time. Would we have done better? It's not hard to answer that question, isn't it? I'm sure I would have been in a monastery. So probably. Well, maybe not yeah well maybe not he definitely would so so john so john the fearless and he gets his name doesn't he because he's actually been on a crusade a disastrous crusade to try and stop the turks from yes from capturing constantia he watched um watched didn't he while everybody else was killed it was it's horrible and we should say that it's it's a
他们一直在旅行。我们会做得更好吗？回答这个问题并不难，对吧？我确信我会去当修道士。所以很可能。好吧，也许不会……好吧，也许不会，他绝对会。所以——所以无畏的约翰——他之所以有了这个绰号，是因为他曾去参加十字军东征，那是一次灾难性的十字军东征，企图阻止土耳其人从……是的，阻止他们攻占君士坦丁堡。他眼睁睁地看着……看着其他人被杀，太可怕了。我们必须说，这是一个
kind of european coalition and he is the leader, the military leader and the English, because we have to talk also about the English they promised to come but they didn't show up thank you very much we knew it was going to go wrong but he gets this name, Saint-Pierre Fearless Jean Saint-Pierre, Jean de Réz we've had Philip the Bold, now we'veierre, Fearless. Jean Saint-Pierre, Gains on the Rays. We've had Philip the Bold.
欧洲联盟，他是领袖，军事领袖，而英国人——因为我们也不得不谈谈英国人——他们答应来，但根本没出现。非常感谢，我们早就知道会出事。但他得到了这个名字——让·桑·佩尔（Jean sans Peur），无畏的让。让·桑·佩尔，盖恩斯·昂·雷（Gains on the Rays）。我们有过勇敢的菲利普。
Now we've got John the Fearless. And John the Fearless commissions the assassination of Louis, the Duke of Orléans in Paris. And Louis leaves a son, Charles, who, and am I getting this right? And I hope this isn't confusing the listeners. He is the son-in-law of Bernard, Count of Armagnac. And so this kind of basically civil war in France that starts to tear
现在我们有了无畏的约翰。无畏的约翰策划了在巴黎刺杀奥尔良公爵路易的行动。路易留下了一个儿子，查理。我没记错吧？我希望这没有把听众搞糊涂。他是阿马尼亚克伯爵伯纳德的女婿。所以这场开始将法国撕裂的法国国内战争，
France apart is between the Armagnacs and the Burgundians. Yes, it's between the French called the Armagnacs and the Burgundians. And this is important for English history because as France starts to tear itself to pieces with the
实际上是在阿马尼亚克派和勃艮第派之间展开。是的，是在被称为阿马尼亚克派的法国人与勃艮第人之间。这对于英国历史很重要，因为当法国在
Armagnacci Orleanists on one side and the Burgundians on the other, in 1415, England's most formidable military leader. You don't like him. You don't rate him. Well, we're not going to get into that now, but he's a formidable military leader. Lands in France and wins another stunning victory at Agincourt. It is.
一边的阿马尼亚克派（奥尔良派）和另一边的勃艮第派的内斗中四分五裂时，在1415年，英格兰最强大的军事统帅——你不太喜欢他。你对他的评价不高。好吧，我们现在不扯这个了，但他是一位强大的军事统帅。登陆法国，并在阿金库尔再次取得了惊人的胜利。确实如此。
So this is part. So when we talk about Burgundy, basically, it's a kind of three way swirl, tangle, battle between the French, this emergent Burgundian state and England. Yes. So, and because there is that civil war in France, the English, Henry V, he can come from Normandy after Agincourt. He can easily come close to Paris. And then the enemies, the internal enemies in France, they decide we have to make good, we have to make peace. And they are going to organize a peace conference on the bridge,
所以这就是部分原因。因此，当我们谈论勃艮第时，它基本上是法国、这个新兴的勃艮第国家与英格兰之间三方角力、纠缠和战斗。是的。而且因为法国发生了内战，英国的亨利五世在阿金库尔战役后得以从诺曼底出发。他可以轻而易举地逼近巴黎。于是，法国国内的敌人决定，我们必须言归于好，我们必须媾和。他们将在一座桥上组织一次和平会议，
one of the most famous bridges in French history, also a forgotten bridge. But it's in Montereau, 100 kilometers on the south of Paris. And you have to see, you have the French Armagnac delegation on one side, the Burgundian with John the Fearless on the other side. They come near to each other and then john the fearless he's really a great prince he um he goes down on his knees and then he will be assassinated as a as a duck hey there will be the acts of treason of france on the on the skull of it will create a a hole oh you say the hole on the skull. It will create a hole.
那是法国历史上最著名的桥梁之一，也是一座被遗忘的桥梁。但它在蒙特罗（Montereau），位于巴黎以南100公里处。你们想象一下，一边是法国阿马尼亚克代表团，另一边是以无畏的约翰为首的勃艮第代表团。他们走近彼此，然后无畏的约翰——他真的是个伟大的君主——他单膝跪地，然后他就被当成一条狗一样刺杀了。那是法国对头骨的叛国行为，会在……哦，你说是头骨上的洞。它会造成一个洞。
Oh, you say it, a hole in the skull. Yes, a hole in the skull. And it's in that hole that... That the English come through. In England. I remember that from A-level. You should go to Montereau. The bridge is still there.
哦，你是这么说的，头骨上的洞。是的，头骨上的洞。正是在那个洞里……英国人长驱直入。在英格兰。我从A-level考试里还记得这个。你们应该去蒙特罗看看。那座桥还在。
Now it's a concrete bridge, of course. And that is very important. You have to look for just a little signboard saying that the Duke of Burgundy, it's just very little, that he was killed as a dog in September 1419. So when you get back at your feet after reading that little board sign, you realize that you are standing in the shadow of a huge Castrian statue of Napoleon. France summarized in one page. Well, there you go.
当然，现在是一座混凝土桥。这非常重要。你得去找一块小路标，上面非常简单地写着，勃艮第公爵于1419年9月像条狗一样被杀。所以当你读完那块小路标、直起腰来时，你会意识到自己正站在拿破仑巨型青铜雕像的阴影下。一页纸就总结了法国。好吧，就是这样。
So French. Is it not important that the person who is seen to be behind this assassination of John the Fearless, and it's kind of like a mafia sequence. So the Duke of Orleans has been murdered. Now John the Fearless has been murdered. But the person who is seen as being behind it is the dauphin the son yeah he's present the son of charles the sixth of france the heir to the french throne and so the burgundians in the wake of john the fearless's assassination blame the french monarchy and there is an
难道不是吗？那个被认为是一手策划了无畏的约翰刺杀案的人——这就像一集黑手党连续剧：奥尔良公爵被谋杀了，现在无畏的约翰也被谋杀了。但被认为幕后黑手的是王太子（the dauphin），也就是那个儿子。是的，他当时在场。法王查理六世的儿子，法国王位的继承人。于是勃艮第人在无畏的约翰被刺杀后，将矛头指向了法国王室，而
alternative king in the form of Henry V waiting to take over. Right, stop. Tom, the producer told me two minutes ago to take us into a break. You derailed that by talking too much. So we're now going to take a break to have some adverts. Although, of course, if you're a member of the Restless History Club, you won't be getting the adverts. And what insane value that membership of that club is, isn't it, Donald? What is it, £6 a month?
以亨利五世为形式的另一个国王正翘首以待准备接管。好了，停。汤姆，制作人两分钟前刚告诉我要进广告。你扯得太多，把这事给搅黄了。所以我们现在要进广告了。不过当然了，如果你是“历史其余部分”俱乐部的会员，你是不会听到广告的。而且加入这个俱乐部的会员价值简直疯狂，不是吗，唐纳德？多少钱来着，一个月6英镑？
It's incredibly cheap. I mean, that's nothing. Anyway, that's the advert for our club. Right, we're going into the break, and then Bart will come back and he will talk to us about a very exciting man, Philip the Good. entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the rest of the entertainment.com that's the rest is history uh unless tom derails this again uh we are talking about
便宜得难以置信。我的意思是，这根本不算什么。不管怎样，那是我们俱乐部的广告。好了，我们要进广告了，然后巴特会回来，跟我们聊聊一个非常令人兴奋的人物——好人菲利普。娱乐。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、八卦猛料的绝佳去处。在问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部，如果你想收听无广告音频、独家加更节目并提前获得现场门票，请前往 the rest is entertainment.com。这就是《历史的其余部分》。除非汤姆再次把这事搅黄——我们正在讨论
the burgundians we have seen off philip the bold and john the fearless so we're now on to number three philip the good we are in what 1419 and bart? And Bart Van Loo, Mr. Burgundy, the Edward Gibbon of the Burgundians, is going to take us through it. So Philip the Good, you describe him in your book as an erotomaniac. Oh, yes, yes. Incredibly oversexed is the title of one chapter. 26 bastards. 26 bastards. But that are the official numbers.
勃艮第人。我们已经送走了勇敢的菲利普和无畏的约翰，现在我们来到了第三位——好人菲利普。我们现在是1419年吗，巴特？而勃艮第先生、勃艮第人的爱德华·吉本——巴特·范·洛，将带着我们继续往下讲。所以好人菲利普，你在书里把他描述为一个色情狂。哦，是的，是的。“极其好色”是其中一章的标题。26个私生子。26个私生子。但那是官方数字。
So unofficially, it should be 73 i think but he was traveling a lot as i said 73 that's almost as many is that what happens if you travel is that i mean you've mentioned traveling already is this just a sort of what is this about traveling and bastards i mean is that just an inevitability i don't but how could you explain it they didn't show each other very much, the Duke and his wife. A girl in every trading centre. I have to say that my wife, she called me yesterday, and I'm doing a Burgundian tournée now in Flemish and Dutch theatres. And she said, Bart, I don't want to bother what you're doing,
所以非官方的数字，我想应该有73个。但他经常旅行，正如我所说。73个，几乎有那么多。这是旅行导致的吗？你刚才已经提到旅行了，这究竟是怎么回事？关于旅行和私生子，难道这是不可避免的吗？我不知道，但你怎么解释呢？公爵和他的妻子并不经常见面。每个贸易中心都有一个姑娘。我得说，我妻子昨天刚给我打电话，我现在正在法兰德斯和荷兰的剧院里进行勃艮第巡演。她说：“巴特，我不想打扰你在做什么，
but you're travelling a lot now. Oh, no. Oh, dear. Those telltale words. what you're doing but you're traveling a lot now which oh no oh dear don't those dread those those telltale words okay if he's going around cheating on his wife and having loads of bastards why is he called philip the good he sounds like the good philip the good that is very it's centuries later that we call it good so that's it's it doesn't because it's that's a posterior uh way of seeing things but we have to imagine Philip the Good. He's 23 years old. He's in Ghent in the Prinzenhof.
但你现在旅行得太多了。”哦，不。哦，天哪。那些意味深长的话。你在做什么，但你现在旅行得太多了。哦，不。哦，天哪。可怕的、那些意味深长的话。好吧，如果他到处对妻子不忠、生了一堆私生子，为什么他还被叫作“好人菲利普”？他听起来像个好人。好人菲利普，那是几个世纪后我们才这样称呼他的。所以这不是因为……这是一种事后的看法。但我们必须想象好人菲利普。他当时23岁。他在根特的普林森霍夫宫（Prinzenhof）。
And then he hears about it. It's a bishop. He's knocking on the door. He says, your father is being killed in the bridge of Montereau. And he's there with his wife, his wife, Michelle of France. And they faint. They can't accept what happened. They can't understand
然后他听说了这件事。有个主教在敲门。他说：“你父亲在蒙特罗桥上被杀了。”他当时和他的妻子、法兰西的米歇尔在一起。他们昏厥了过去。他们无法接受发生的事情。他们无法理解
what happened. And you should know that he's married to this Michelle de France and that she's the sister of the crown prince who commanded the murder on the bridge of Montereau. Just if you imagine what those family parties are going to be afterwards.
发生了什么。你还应该知道，他娶了这位米歇尔·德·法兰西，而她是下令谋杀蒙特罗桥的皇太子之妹。只要想象一下，以后那些家庭聚会会是什么样。
Christmas will be a bit difficult he when he awakens up uh after being fainted the first thing he cries he's screaming to his to his wife he's he's he's yelling michelle your brother killed my father well it is shakespeare but in real life and now now it's up to him. Hey, he who will organise the most exquisite banquets and tournaments, who will be the most important founding father of the low countries, the man who will create the golden fleece, Philip the Good, the man who six centuries
圣诞节会有点困难，当他苏醒时，呃，在晕厥之后，他喊出的第一句话是对他的妻子，他尖叫着，他大喊：米歇尔，你哥哥杀了我父亲！好吧，这是莎士比亚，但在现实生活中，现在这得看他了。嘿，那个将组织最精美宴会和比武大会的人，低地国家最重要的奠基人之一，创造金羊毛勋章的人，好人菲利普，这个人在六个世纪
later will make it to the cover of a book. True fame. That's a very, very good part. Well done. So looking at Philip the Good, very good. Very good, Bart. Well done. So looking at Philip the Good, could we do it in two parts? First of all,
之后将登上书的封面。真正的名气。这真是一个非常非常好的部分。干得好。所以审视好人菲利普，非常好。非常好，巴特。干得好。所以审视好人菲利普，我们能分两部分来谈吗？首先，
could we look at his engagement in the Hundred Years' War? Because as Barry Grogan said, this is the Joan of Arc sequence and so it's probably something that people in England would be interested in. And then could we look at
我们能看看他介入百年战争的情况吗？因为正如巴里·格罗根所说，这是圣女贞德的序列，所以这可能是英国人会感兴趣的事情。然后我们能看看
the splendour, the tournaments, the dwarves, the chivalry, all that kind of stuff. So we'll come to that. But first of all, in the wake of John the Fearless' murder, Philip the Good
金碧辉煌、比武大会、侏儒、骑士精神，诸如此类的事情。所以我们会谈到这些。但首先，在无畏者约翰被谋杀之后，好人菲利普
signs the Treaty of Troyes. The Tricherie, as the French still say today. No, as a sensible rapprochement with the rightful King of France, Henry V. Yes, and now you can put some trumpets. It's possible because Henry V
签署了《特鲁瓦条约》。法国人今天仍然称之为“背叛”（Tricherie）。不，这是与法国合法国王亨利五世的明智和解。是的，现在你可以放一些小号声了。这是可能的，因为亨利五世
will marry Catherine, the daughter of King Charles VI, after the death of whom he will be the next king of France. Henry V laughed up his sleeve. He had spent three years of conquering Normandy and now in one day France is being dropped in his lap. So you should put some English trumpets now
将娶国王查理六世的女儿凯瑟琳，在他死后，他将成为法国的下一任国王。亨利五世暗自窃笑。他花了三年时间征服诺曼底，现在法国在一天之内就被送到了他的怀里。所以你现在应该放一些英国的小号声。
okay Jack if you could have some English trumpets so the Burgundians entered the Hundred Years War basically on the English side and Charles VI the Mad King, dies. His son, Charles VII, has been dispossessed and basically gets pushed south of the Loire. He's desperately struggling to keep a hold on this kind of
好的，杰克，如果你能来点英国小号的话——勃艮第人基本上是站在英国一边加入了百年战争，而疯王查理六世去世了。他的儿子查理七世被剥夺了继承权，基本上被逼到了卢瓦尔河以南。他正拼命挣扎着保住这片法国的
rump of France. And it's at this point that a witch appears. Yeah, definitely a witch. A sorceress. A sorceress. An evil sorceress known to posterity as Joan of Arc. Joan of Arc. So Joan of Arc with her
残余领土。正是在这个时候，一个女巫出现了。是的，绝对是个女巫。一个女巫。一个女巫。一个被后世称为圣女贞德的邪恶女巫。圣女贞德。所以圣女贞德带着她的
necromantic powers. Tom Lett, Bart, tell the story. Sorry, sorry. I'm so excited about it. Tom, let Bart tell the story. Sorry, sorry, sorry. I'm so excited about it. He can't stop talking, Bart. So Joan of Arc saves all your from the English attack. And then in due course, she gets captured by Burgundians.
巫术力量——汤姆·莱特，巴特，来讲讲这个故事。对不起，对不起。我太兴奋了。汤姆，让巴特来讲这个故事。对不起，对不起，对不起。我太兴奋了。他停不下来，巴特。所以圣女贞德把你们所有人从英国人的进攻中拯救出来。然后不久，她就被勃艮第人俘虏了。
And what do the Burgundians do with her? It's still going on. I don't have to say anything. Bart can leave. I mean, sorry. I'm getting excited. But what I like to say is that she's doing that enormous, gigantic, historical trip from Don Rémy to Chine, where he will convince the French king that he will give the military elite of his army to her. It's incredible. It's something we can't understand.
然后勃艮第人对她做了什么？还在继续呢。我什么都不用说。巴特可以离开了。我的意思是，对不起。我太兴奋了。但我想说的是，她进行了那次从栋雷米到希农的巨大、宏伟的历史之旅，在那里她将说服法国国王把军队的军事精英交给他。这太不可思议了。这是我们无法理解的事情。
It's a story. It's a story tale. I don't understand it it's it's it's it's it's a story it's it's how would you say the story tale i don't know it's a fairy tale it's it's incredible to to understand uh and she is doing that and then she will it's she will uh conquer orleans that the french always talk about and now we have zemmour in french in france he's still it's incredible but he's uh he's putting again french uh joan of arc in the at the first place now but he's putting again French Joan of Arc in the first place now. But that's another story. We're not going to talk about Éric Zemmour, and we should cut this out of the podcast. No publicity for Éric Zemmour.
这是一个故事。这是一个童话故事。我无法理解，这、这、这、这是一个故事，这、你怎么说这个童话故事呢，我不知道，这是一个童话，这、这不可思议，去理解，呃，她正在这样做，然后她将，她将，呃，征服奥尔良，法国人总是谈论这个，现在我们在法国有了泽穆尔，他仍然，这太不可思议了，但他，呃，他又把法国的圣女贞德放在了首位，现在，但他又把法国的圣女贞德放在了首位。但那是另一个故事了。我们不打算谈论埃里克·泽穆尔，我们应该把这段从播客里剪掉。不给埃里克·泽穆尔做宣传。
Okay, forget him. And then she will conquer everything we know about it. She will go to the Sacre of the King of France in Reims. She realized it. And then we have Charles VII. He's being crowned and sacred as the new French king. And then it will be, as Tom already announced, it's by Compiègne that the troops of Burgundy will capture Joan of Arc.
好了，忘掉他吧。然后她将征服我们所知道的一切。她将前往兰斯参加法国国王的加冕礼。她实现了这一点。然后我们有了查理七世。他被加冕并涂油成为新的法国国王。然后，正如汤姆已经预告的那样，勃艮第军队正是在贡比涅俘虏了圣女贞德。
And Joan of Arc will be led to Philip the Good. It's incredible. You have two of the main, the most important people of that century. They are facing each other. And thanks to God, we have the chroniclers. The chroniclers, they tell us everything. They tell us that there are
圣女贞德将被带到好人菲利普面前。这太不可思议了。这个世纪最重要的两个主要人物。他们面对面了。谢天谢地，我们有编年史家。编年史家，他们把一切都告诉了我们。他们告诉我们，在玛格丽特·德·弗兰姆斯的衣服上有
200 squirrels in the clothes of Margaret of Flames. If we want to know anything, we can check it out. But there, there's nothing. They don't say a word about the meeting between Philip the Good and Joan of Arc. That's amazing. I think she, she standed up to him. I think she maybe spook up against him. Do you think it's because of shame? Do they feel embarrassed that they then sell her on to the English who burn her? No, I don't think so. Because Philip the Good, he's just thinking,
200只松鼠。如果我们想知道什么，我们可以查证。但是在那，什么也没有。他们对好人菲利普和圣女贞德的会面闭口不谈。这太神奇了。我想她，她顶撞了他。我想她也许对他说过重话。你认为这是因为羞耻吗？他们是否因为后来把她卖给将她烧死的英国人而感到尴尬？不，我不这么认为。因为好人菲利普，他只是在想，
what can I do? And he is having trouble with England again at that moment. And for the woolcloth industry, it's so important that the relations, the economic relations with England are fine. No, excellent. So it's just, how do you say it? We call it, it's like selling a cow.
我能做什么？而且他当时又和英国人有了麻烦。对于毛纺织工业来说，与英国的关系，经济关系良好是如此重要。不，太棒了。所以这只是，你怎么说呢？我们称之为，就像卖一头牛。
It just sells Joan of Arc to England. And we know the Englands are the bad guys because it's the English people who burned Joan of Arc. Well, I don't think that's, I mean, steady on. Yes, they did it. Calm down, Bert. Do you know why they did it? Because she's a witch. Because they want...
他只是把圣女贞德卖给了英国。我们知道英国人是坏人，因为是英国人烧死了圣女贞德。嗯，我不认为那是——我是说，稳着点。是的，他们确实这么做了。冷静点，伯特。你知道他们为什么这么做吗？因为她是女巫。因为他们想……
But she isn't a witch. Even Philip the Good didn't think she was a witch. He doesn't think about witchcraft. She's kind of the Greta Thunberg of the 15th century. Yes, in some kind. And so the English, they will burner just to prove that it's a witch who helped the French king to his
但她不是女巫。连好人菲利普都不认为她是女巫。他根本不考虑巫术。她有点像15世纪的格蕾塔·滕贝格。是的，某种程度上是这样。所以英国人烧死她只是为了证明是一个女巫帮助了法国国王登上
throne. It's only about politicals. That's everything. And that's... If you can't stand the heat, don't meddle in politics. I think listeners should be warned that that, of course, is very much a Belgian perspective on...
王位。这全是为了政治。仅此而已。而且那……如果你受不了热，就别插手政治。我想应该警告听众，这当然在很大程度上是比利时人的视角，关于……
And therefore not necessarily I think listeners should be warned that that, of course, is very much a Belgian perspective on. And therefore not necessarily to be taken entirely seriously. So this witch is so Joan of Arc, the witch is burnt. But then it all goes wrong for England because the Burgundians treacherously jump ship in 1435. They go back on their treaty with England and sign up to France. Yes. That essentially dooms England, the possibility of England holding on to France. And that's the end of the, it's almost the end of the Hundred Years War, who will follow in 1453, a little bit later on.
因此未必——我想应该警告听众，这当然在很大程度上是比利时人的视角，关于……因此未必能完全当真。所以这个女巫，也就是圣女贞德，这个女巫被烧死了。但随后英国的一切都开始走下坡路，因为勃艮第人在1435年背信弃义地倒戈了。他们背叛了与英国的条约，转而投向法国。是的，这基本上注定了英国的命运，英国保住法国的可能性化为乌有。而这也就是，几乎是百年战争的结局，百年战争将在1433年、稍晚一点结束。
But it's right it's the end of the English power in France and that's what the French forgot because they're always talking about the treason of the Burgundians but 15 years later
但没错，这是英国在法国权力的终结，而法国人却忘记了这一点，因为他们总是谈论勃艮第人的背叛，但15年以后，
Philip de Goutte he's forgetting about it he throws the English outside of the Good, he's forgetting about it. He throws the English outside of the country. He's thinking about power. It's what we call a cynical way of
菲利普·勒·邦（好人菲利普），他把这抛在脑后，把英国人赶出了好人菲利普，他把这抛在脑后。他把英国人赶出了国家。他考虑的是权力。这就是我们所说的
trying to get in power. He's moving between France and England, weakening them both so he could be the first man in Europe, and he could go on by puzzling together the low countries. At this point, he has this realm, which basically goes from the low countries.
试图夺权的虚伪方式。他在法国和英国之间腾挪闪避，削弱两国的实力，从而使自己成为欧洲第一人，并能够继续拼凑低地国家。此时，他拥有了这个基本上从低地国家延伸出去的王国。
So it's expanded, hasn't it? It's basically modern-day Holland, Belgium, Luxembourg, down into kind of sort of central-eastern France, i.e. Burgundy. But he's also got the most glittering court in europe he's got these absolute economic powerhouses of gent and bruges so is he basically the top dog in europe at this point oh yes he is he is because he's weakening france he's weakening um england and he's the the great great Duke of the Occident,
所以它扩张了，不是吗？它基本上是今天的荷兰、比利时、卢森堡，一直延伸到中东部法国，也就是勃艮第。但他也拥有欧洲最耀眼的宫殿，拥有根特和布鲁日这两个绝对的经济超级大国，所以此时他基本上是欧洲的老大吗？哦，是的，他是，他是，因为他在削弱法国，他在削弱嗯英国，他是西方伟大无比的公爵，
as he is called. And he wants to be a king, like his son further on wants to be a king. They will almost, one centimeter of that, they will succeed almost, but they will fail eventually. But he's the number one in Europe. And he wants to show off.
正如人们所称呼的那样。他想成为一个国王，就像他后来的儿子想成为国王一样。他们几乎——就差一厘米，他们几乎成功了，但最终还是失败了。不过他是欧洲的第一名。他想炫耀。
So now we get into the banquet. So Bart, could I just read an extract from your book? Yes. Which I enjoyed so much, I wrote it down. And this is a description of a typical Burgundian banquet. The cook stuffed bellies with strings of sausages that spurted onto the table like grandiose rosary beads when the belly was cut open. They decorated bustards with precious stones, dressed hazel grouses in golden habits, served pork in the shape of a fish,
所以现在我们进入宴会环节。那么巴特，我能读一段你书中的摘录吗？可以，可以，可以。我太喜欢了，把它抄了下来。这是对一场典型的勃艮第宴会的描述：厨师把塞满香肠的肚囊挂在桌上，当肚囊被切开时，香肠就像宏大的念珠一样喷涌到桌子上。他们用宝石装饰鸨鸟，给榛鸡穿上金色的外衣，把猪做成鱼的形状，
fixed a cat's ears on a hare, attached a chicken's head to a rabbit's body, or cooked a dozen gigantic eggs in pork bladders. Is that how you still eat today, Bart? Hi. Oh, there are readers who try to make those gigantic eggs in pork bladders, but it's very complicated. I would love to go to a feast like that. But bladders. But it's very complicated.
给野兔安上猫耳朵，把鸡头安在兔子身上，或者把一打巨大的鸡蛋煮在猪膀胱里。你现在还这么吃吗，巴特？嗨。哦，有些读者试图制作那些装在猪膀胱里的巨大鸡蛋，但这非常复杂。我很想去参加那样的一场盛宴。但膀胱。但这非常复杂。
I would love to go to a feast like that. But somebody could try. Oh, it would be amazing. It would be amazing. And so there was also, how do you say it, a capon dressed in armor sitting astride on those roasted pigs stuffed with those little sausages. And that was carried by four Hungarian dwarves into the...
我很想去参加那样的一场盛宴。但有人可以试试。哦，那太棒了。那太棒了。还有，你怎么说，一只穿着盔甲的阉鸡骑在那些塞满了小香肠的烤猪背上。那是由四个匈牙利侏儒抬进……
Okay, so now the dwarves. So let's get to the... Talk us through the dwarves. Why the obsession with dwarves? I don't know why. It's just they bought them in Eastern Europe. And it's incredible. You see them for the first time at the end of the 14th century.
好的，现在是侏儒。让我们来谈谈……给我们讲讲侏儒。为什么对侏儒如此痴迷？我不知道为什么。这只是因为他们在东欧买下了他们。这太不可思议了。你在14世纪末第一次看到他们。
They were going on in 1430 with the marriage of philip the good then you see them also in 1454 with the banquet of the pheasant and they're and they're often called hans so that is uh no hans is a giant because you have a dwarf and a giant and the giant is called hans and i think he's going on for almost 30 or 40 years of banquets. So he's like a professional banquet generation. And he's a giant. And he's the guy who leads in an automated elephant
他们在1430年好人菲利普的婚礼上继续出现，然后你在1454年的雉鸡宴上也看到了他们，而且他们经常被称为汉斯——所以那是一个，不，汉斯是一个巨人，因为你有一个侏儒和一个巨人，巨人叫汉斯，我想他参加了差不多30或40年的宴会。所以他就像是一个专业的宴会常客。他是个巨人。而且他是那个牵着一头机器大象入场的人，
with, is it a dwarf on top who's symbolising the Church of Constantinople or something? It's the most beautiful wife, but in real, it was a man who was changed into a woman. So yes's it's it's incredible you've also got at one point a wild boar being ridden by a gnome i said they were massive lads i mean you get a fire-breathing peacock you get a gigantic pie
大象上面是不是有个侏儒象征着君士坦丁堡教会什么的？那是位最美丽的妻子，但实际上，那是一个被变成女人的男人。所以是的，这、这、这太不可思议了，你有时还会看到一头野猪背上骑着一个小矮人，我说他们真是些庞然大物，我的意思是，你会看到喷火的孔雀，你会看到一个巨大的馅饼，
with 28 musicians in it it's it's and now that's a lot of fun and god knows that i like but you have to ask one question why did they do so that's the question to ask why for the past because we are we explained a hundred years war so we have the english and the france they have become a pale become a pale copy of their ancient power they are tired almost passed out there is a power vacuum and the burgundians want to fill that up but they are very well aware of the fact that there are no kings they are just dukes so they jump in the vacuum with pomp and circumstance with medieval bling bling so that everybody around only could say one thing that is what real kings are about those dukes are really royal right and if they hadn't made artworks of their feasts and banquets in dutch we should have been looking
里面有28个音乐家，这、这，现在这很有趣，天知道我有多喜欢，但你必须问一个问题：他们为什么这么做？这就是要问的问题：为什么为了过去——因为我们解释了百年战争，所以我们有英国和法国，它们已经成了它们昔日权力的苍白副本，它们几乎筋疲力尽，快要晕厥了，那里出现了权力真空，而勃艮第人想要填补这个真空。但他们非常清楚这样一个事实：他们不是国王，他们只是公爵。所以他们带着浮华与排场、中世纪的珠光宝气跳进了这个权力真空，好让周围每个人都只能说一件事：这就是真正的国王该有的样子，这些公爵真是具有皇家风范，对吧？如果他们没有把他们的盛宴和宴会做成艺术品的话，在荷兰语中，我们本该去
for another word to talk about our burgundian pleasures we say in dutch my father is a real burgundian and it means that he likes eating, drinking, feasting. And having fun with dwarves. So these dwarves, sorry just to say. Tom loves the dwarves. But I'll tell you why. I'll tell you why. Because when I did A-Level, I read this famous book
寻找另一个词来谈论我们的勃艮第式享乐。我们在荷兰语中说“我父亲是个真正的勃艮第人”，意思是喜欢吃喝玩乐。并且和侏儒一起寻开心。所以这些侏儒，抱歉说一下。汤姆喜欢侏儒。但我会告诉你为什么。我告诉你为什么。因为自我上高级水准考试（A-Level）以来，我读了这本由荷兰历史学家约翰·赫伊津哈写的著名书。
by a Dutch historian, Jan Huizinga. Of course. In English. I should say Huizing, Jan Huizinga, which in English, Huizinga, sorry, is translated into English as The Waning of the Middle Ages. And there was a whole thing about dwarves in that. So there's Madame d'Or, the blonde dwarf of Philip the Good, who was made to wrestle at a court festival with the acrobat Hans, who I guess is this giant.
当然。用英文。我应该说赫伊津，约翰·赫伊津哈，在英语中，赫伊津哈，抱歉，被翻译成英文叫《中世纪的衰落》。里面有很多关于侏儒的内容。比如好人菲利普的金发侏儒多尔夫人，被安排在宫廷节日上与杂技演员汉斯摔跤，我猜汉斯就是那个巨人。
At the wedding feasts of Charles the Bold, who's Philip's son, Madame de Beaugrand, the female dwarf of mademoiselle of burgundy enters dressed like a shepherdess mounted on a golden lion larger than a horse i mean it's all it's on one level completely odd but on another kind of magnificent well that's what it's about though isn't it about a display of magnificence as bart said that's all about status right yes just to that's what it's about, though, isn't it? About a display of magnificence. As Bart said, that's all about status, right? Yes, just to show off. And it's so you have, then that is, it's little big history. You get little anecdotes, and they are fun. We are, we're talking and laughing about them. But it illustrates the political powers moving during the Hundred Years' War. So that's the little big history. La grande petite histoire est ce honoré de Balzac. And that's what I like doing in a history book.
在菲利普的儿子——大胆的查尔斯的婚礼上，博格朗夫人，勃艮第小姐的女侏儒入场时打扮成牧羊女，骑着一只比马还大的金狮子。我的意思是，从某种层面来看这完全怪异，但从另一方面来看又极其宏伟。嗯，这就是它的意义所在，不是吗？关于宏伟的展示？正如巴特所说，这全都是为了地位，对吧？是的，就是为了炫耀。所以你有了，然后那是，这是微观宏大历史（little big history）。你得到了许多小轶事，它们很有趣。我们在谈论它们并付诸一笑。但它说明了百年战争期间政治力量的流变。这就是微观宏大历史。伟大的微观历史（La grande petite histoire），奥诺雷·德·巴尔扎克如是说。这就是我喜欢在历史书中做的事情。
But there is one other thing, and you mentioned it very fleetingly, Bart, and that's the Order of the Golden Fleece. Yes, yes, yes. So the Order of the Golden Fleece, so you're talking about how the Duke of Burgundy is not a king, but the Order of the Golden Fleece becomes the preeminent chivalric order in the
但还有一件事，你非常匆忙地提到了它，巴特，那就是金羊毛勋章。是的，是的，是的。所以金羊毛勋章，你是说勃艮第公爵虽然不是国王，但金羊毛勋章却成了
whole of Europe, doesn't it? Yes, it's sending out an international message. So it's a chivalric order. Everybody knows about a chivalric order. Normally only kings have them. And he's sending out an international message. It was a message laden with brocade, velvet and jewels. But that made it no less heartful thumping of the burgundian nose
整个欧洲最卓越的骑士团，对吗？是的，它发出了一个国际信号。所以它是一个骑士团。每个人都知道骑士团。通常只有国王才有骑士团。而他发出了一个国际信号。这是一个充满锦缎、天鹅绒和珠宝的信息。但这并没有减少勃艮第人对法国和英国
at france and england and the fact he was saying without bathing a night that he took his place beside the kings of england and france and that he was thinking maybe of becoming king himself yeah and and so it's it's it's it's it's it's a chivalric order but it's also political play and to this day, I mean Elizabeth II our queen in the UK is a member of it well that's because it's taken on by the Habsburgs isn't it
挑衅的力度，事实上，他不用沐浴一个夜晚，就让自己坐在了与英法国王平起平坐的位置上，并且他可能在考虑自己成为国王。是的，所以它、它、它、它、它、它既是一个骑士团，也是一场政治博弈。直到今天，我是说英国女王伊丽莎白二世也是它的成员。哦，那是因为它被哈布斯堡王朝继承了，不是吗？
they basically inherit it so it's Nicolas Sarkozy see, yes he's a member of it too do you have aspirations of being a member of it, Bart? Of the Golden Fleece? I think it's impossible. You should be a leader of a country or an aristocratic...
他们基本上继承了它，所以尼古拉·萨科齐，是的，他也是它的成员。巴特，你有渴望成为它的成员吗？金羊毛勋章？我觉得这是不可能的。你必须是一个国家的领导人或者贵族……
You need to carve out a kingdom in the Middle Era. Maybe the Légion d'Honneur in France. It would be nice. But France already gave me a French woman, so that's even better so dynastic dynastic power building going on let me wrestle this back to the narrative so we've had Philip the Bold
你需要在中世纪开辟一个王国。也许是法国的荣誉军团勋章。那会很不错。但法国已经给了我一个法国女人，所以这甚至更好。所以这里正在进行王朝权力的构建。让我把话题拉回叙事上来。所以我们有了大胆的菲利普、
John the Fearless, Philip the Good dies in 1433 and he has succeeded admittedly slightly confusingly by Charles the Bold so we've got another Bold though that's only in English, isn't it? It's not in French. Yes, it's Charles le Temeraire.
无畏者约翰，好人菲利普在1433年去世，继位的是——虽然说实话有点让人混淆——大胆的查尔斯。所以我们又有一个“大胆的”，虽然那只是在英语里，对吧？法语里不是这样的。是的，他是查理·勒·泰梅赖尔（Charles le Téméraire）。
It's a better name. We should have called him Charles the Reckless, I think. That would be better because the bold, I'm sorry, it's not good. Okay. So Charles is very different from his erotomaniac father. He's very sort of repressed and violent, isn't he? He obviously has some kinds of hang-ups and issues.
这是个更好的名字。我想我们应该叫他“鲁莽的查尔斯”。那样会更好，因为“大胆的”，对不起，这不太好。好的。所以查尔斯和他的色情狂父亲非常不同。他非常压抑和暴力，不是吗？他显然有一些心理阴结和问题。
Maybe he's homosexual. We don't know. He doesn't have any bastards, just one daughter, and that is maybe his biggest political failure. Right, because it's at this point that Burgundy... Am I right in thinking it's about this point, that if you think of it as a sort of trajectory, Burgundy has peaked and is about to dip.
也许他是同性恋。我们不知道。他没有私生子，只有一个女儿，这也许是他最大的政治失败。没错，因为正是在这个时候，勃艮第……我想得对吗，如果把它看作一种轨迹，勃艮第已经达到了顶峰，正要开始走下坡路。
Is that right? Yes, but it's peaking still the first 10 years of Charles the Bold, Charles the Reckless. Because, let's put it this way, we have Burgundy in the south, the old duchy. And then Philip the Bold and Philip the Good,
是这样吗？是的，但在大胆的查尔斯、鲁莽的查尔斯执政的前十年，它仍然处于顶峰。因为，让我们这样来看，我们在南部有勃艮第，即老公爵领。然后是大胆的菲利普和好人菲利普，
they put together the low countries in the north but it and burgundy the old duchy became a kind of satellite because it's it's not relied to and then philip the bold in 10 years time with a lot of conquering stuff he's going to to to combine those two um territorials with with with Alsace and everything German and French and parts of France and Germany. He will conquer them and then you have one little, how do you call it?
他们在北部把低地国家拼凑在了一起，但勃艮第作为老公爵领变成了一种卫星领地，因为它并不依赖于……然后大胆的菲利普在10年的时间里，通过大量的征服，将这两个领地……将阿尔萨斯以及所有德国和法国的东西、法国和德国的部分地区结合起来。他将征服它们，然后你就会拥有一个小小的，你叫它什么？
Ein Mittelreich of Deutsch. The middle empire. He made it but he made it too much with a kind of hubris. So he finds his death in the snow of Nancy, where he's beaten up by the Swiss.
德意志中世纪帝国（Ein Mittelreich of Deutsch）。中间帝国。他做到了，但他带着一种狂妄自大做到了这一点。因此他在南锡的雪地里丧命，在那里他被瑞士人击败了。
But the Swiss were sponsored by Louis XI, the French king. The universal spider. Yes, the French king. The universal spider. Yes, the universal spider. For the French people, it's like winning the World Cup of football, of soccer, without being there. They just sponsored the Swiss to do the dirty job for them.
但瑞士人是由法国国王路易十一资助的。万能的蜘蛛。是的，法国国王。万能的蜘蛛。是的，万能的蜘蛛。对法国人民来说，这就像是不费吹灰之力就赢得了足球世界杯的冠军。他们只是资助瑞士人来替他们干脏活。
And then, what happens then is that after the death of Charles the Bold, Burgundy becomes, how do you say it, with a giant on wooden feet? I don't know how you say it, with a giant on wooden feet? I don't know how you say it. On clay feet. Feet of clay, yeah.
然后，接下来发生的是，在大胆的查尔斯死后，勃艮第变成了，你怎么说来着，脚踩木脚的巨人？我不知道你怎么说，脚踩木脚的巨人？我不知道你怎么说。泥足巨人。泥足，对。
Feet of clay. So at that point, after his death, Burgundy becomes a colossus of clay feet, on clay feet. And so France and the Holy Roman Empire, they are eager to reconquer what they lost. And they're going to fight up. And they're going to, for instance, everything in the South, they to reconquer what they lost and they're gonna fight up and they're gonna for instance everything in the south
泥足。所以在那个时候，他死后，勃艮第变成了一个泥足巨人。因此，法兰西和神圣罗马帝国都渴望重新征服他们失去的东西。他们要反击。他们要，比如说，把南部的一切……重新征服他们失去的东西，他们要反击，他们要，比如说，南部的一切
They will reconquer so the old Dutch of Burden gate It's going back up my friends. Yeah, but in the north they don't succeed Thanks to Mary of Burgundy and Maximilian of Austria so the northern part the low countries will still go on about a century and There we have the real heritage of the Burgundian era. It's that part, because Burgundia itself,
他们都会重新征服，所以旧的勃艮第公爵领……又要回去了，我的朋友们。是的，但在北部他们没有成功，多亏了勃艮第的玛丽和奥地利的马克西米连，所以北部地区，即低地国家，还将延续大约一个世纪。在那里，我们拥有了勃艮第时代真正的遗产。就是那部分，因为勃艮第本身，
it becomes a part of the French crown. So, Bart, Mary, who in English is known as Mary the Rich, I don't know if she is in... Yes, yes, yes, Marie de Rijken, Marie de Rijken, yes. So, Mary the Rich, who is Charles' only surviving child, as you say, marries Maximilian of Habsburg,
它成了法国王冠的一部分。所以，巴特，玛丽，在英语中被称为富有者玛丽，我不知道她是不是在……是的，是的，是的，玛丽·德·赖肯（Marie de Rijken），玛丽·德·赖肯，是的。所以，富有者玛丽，作为查理唯一在世的孩子，正如你所说，嫁给了哈布斯堡王朝的马克西米连，
who then becomes emperor. And it's through that line that Emperor Charles V, Philip II, in the 16th century, inherit the Low Countries, which will, with the Reformation and so on, lead to kind of religious wars and, in the long run, the emergence of the Dutch Republic. And the Spanish Netherlands. And the Spanish Netherlands, yes.
他后来成为了皇帝。正是通过这条线索，16世纪的查理五世皇帝、腓力二世继承了低地国家，这将随着宗教改革等事件，导致某种宗教战争，从长远来看，催生了荷兰共和国。和西属尼德兰。和西属尼德兰，是的。
And what will become afterwards will be Belgium, of course. That's right. And I describe Charles Lecun, as we call him in French. How do you say him? I mean, we say Emperor Charles. And I describe Charles le Quint, as we call him in French. How do you say him? We say Emperor Charles. How do you call him? Charles V?
而后来将变成的是比利时，当然。没错。我把查理勒坎（Charles le Quint），我们在法语中对他的称呼。你怎么称呼他？我的意思是，我们称他为查理皇帝。我把查理勒坎——我们在法语中对他的称呼。你怎么称呼他？我们称他为查理皇帝。你叫他什么？查理五世？
Charles V. But you also have a Charles V in England, so there is no... No, we don't. We only stop at the second of Charles's. Yes, of a Charles V. And I describe him as the last Burgundian because his ultimate dream is to be buried in Chamonix next to the pleurons carved in alabaster by Sluiter next to Philip the Bold and John the Fearless. And it's the biggest frustration of the man who almost has all Europe and the half of the world in his pocket. He wants to be buried as a Burgundian Jew,
查理五世。但你在英国也有一个查理五世，所以没有……不，我们没有。我们的查理只到二世。是的，没有查理五世。我把他描述为最后一个勃艮第人，因为他终极的梦想是死后被埋葬在沙莫尼（Chamonix），躺在由斯吕特（Sluiter）用雪花石膏雕刻的哭丧人雕像旁边，紧挨着大胆的菲利普和无畏者约翰。这是这个几乎将整个欧洲和半个世界都收入囊中的男人的最大挫折。他想作为一个勃艮第人被埋葬，
but that will not happen. So that's interesting part. So in other words, for Charles V, so a man who basically owns much of South America, who's the richest man in the world, probably the most powerful man of the age. So for him, the Burgundian heritage really matters. Is it the romance, the glamour? What is it about Burgundy? Because he was raised by his aunt, Margaret of Austria. We should call her Margaret of Mechelen. That should be better.
但这不会发生。所以这很有趣，巴特。换句话说，对查理五世来说，一个基本上拥有大半个南美洲、世界上最富有的人、可能也是那个时代最有权势的人来说，勃艮第的遗产真的很重要。是那种浪漫主义、魅力吗？勃艮第究竟有什么吸引人的地方？因为他是被他的姑姑、奥地利的玛格丽特抚养长大的。我们应该叫她梅赫伦的玛格丽特。那样更好。
She was never in Vienna, for instance. She raised him in that Burgundian spirit of beauty, of propaganda, of literature, of good eating. And he loves it. And it will stop when he dies, when then we have Philip II, that very severe Catholic, not a party man, it's over. Not a friend of the show.
她从未去过维也纳，比如说。她用那种勃艮第式的精神培养了他——关于美、关于宣传、关于文学、关于美食。而他非常热爱这一切。这一切在他死后画上了句号，那时我们迎来了腓力二世，那个非常严厉的天主教徒，不是一个聚会的人，一切都结束了。不是节目的朋友。
He's not talking Dutch, he's not talking French anymore. It's the end of the Burgundian low countries of the Burgundian era. It is the end of, you say, my book. So at that point, economically, because we haven't massively talked about the economics of it all in this episode. So at that point, Bruges and Ghent anyway have lost their primacy to Antwerp and Amsterdam. Is that right?
他不再说荷兰语，也不再说法语了。这是勃艮第低地国家、勃艮第时代的终结。这就是你书的结局，可以说。那么在那时，在经济上，因为我们在本集节目中没有大量讨论这一切的经济问题——所以在那个时候，布鲁日和根特无论如何已经将它们的首要地位让给了安特卫普和阿姆斯特丹。是这样吗？
Yes. Why does that happen? Well, that has to do with Maximilian of Austria. So we have Bruges and Ghent are the superpowers when we talk about cities in the Middle Ages. But then we have two things. And then you have to help me first in English. We have the problem with the Zwin, that is the water which relies Bruges to the sea. It's drying up.
是的。为什么会这样？这与奥地利的马克西米连有关。所以布鲁日和根特在中世纪的城市中曾是超级大国。但随后发生了两件事。然后你得先在英语上帮帮我。我们遇到了茨温河（Zwin）的问题，那是连接布鲁日和大海的水道。它正在干涸。
Can I say it this way? Yes, it's drying up. That's the first reason. And the second reason is that there is, when Maximilian is coming, is saving Flanders from France after the death of Charles the Bold, but it's a kind of absolute power. He installs it in Flanders, in Brabant. We don't like that here. So there is a kind of civil war going on between Ghent, Bruges and Maximilian.
我能这么说吗？是的，它正在干涸。这是第一个原因。第二个原因在于，当马克西米连到来时——在大胆的查尔斯死后，他把法兰德斯从法国手中拯救出来——但他带来了一种专制统治。他在法兰德斯、布拉班特建立了这种统治。我们这里不喜欢那样。所以根特、布鲁日和马克西米连之间爆发了一场内战。
But Antwerp chooses the side of Maximilian. So after that civilian war, he almost obliged the salesman from Bruges to move to Antwerp. So we have the drying up of Zwin. We have all the salesmen and women, salesmen at the time, going to Antwerp. And then we have the rising of Antwerp. And that will go on for less than a century. But then we have the religion wars, the Catholics and the Calvinists.
但安特卫普站在了马克西米连一边。所以在内战之后，他几乎强迫布鲁日的商人们搬到安特卫普。所以我们有茨温河的干涸。我们有所有的男男女女商人——当时的商人——搬到安特卫普。然后我们迎来了安特卫普的崛起。这种情况持续了不到一个世纪。但随后我们迎来了宗教战争，天主教徒和加尔文主义者。
And then Antwerp will go down and it will be... Amsterdam goes up. Amsterdam will take advantage of that. So Bart, just to end, that's kind of an amazing tour of this fascinating and unjustly forgotten period of European history. Two questions. One from Tom Flanagan.
然后安特卫普将走向衰落，并且将是……阿姆斯特丹崛起。阿姆斯特丹将从中受益。所以巴特，最后总结一下，这是一次对欧洲历史上这个迷人却又被不公正遗忘的时期的高明游历。有两个问题。一个来自汤姆·弗拉纳根。
Could the Low Countries be seen as the successor states to the Duchy? And a more specific one from Patrick Kennedy. To what extent has Burgundy influenced the identity of Belgium? A lot of questions. The first, of course, it is. When we talk about Burgundy now, we talk about wine. We talk about Jan van Eyck. We didn't talk about Jan van Eyck. We should do again. Great altarpiece again. We talk about art, but we should talk, and we never talked about it, about that the Low Countries is really, it is the most visible heritage of the Burgundian era.
低地国家能否被视为公国的心脏继承国？另一个是帕特里克·肯尼迪提出的更具体的问题。勃艮第在多大程度上影响了比利时的身份认同？很多问题。第一个，当然，是的。当我们现在谈论勃艮第时，我们谈论的是葡萄酒。我们谈论的是扬·凡·艾克。我们没有谈论扬·凡·艾克。我们应该再谈谈。又有伟大的祭坛画。我们谈论艺术，但我们应该谈论——而我们从未谈论过这一点——低地国家确实是勃艮第时代最清晰可见的遗产。
And I think that explains maybe the success of my book in our country, because we forgot about it. Because for reasons of national novel, I don't know if you have that concept in England, the national novel, a national history, a national story. Yes, we talk about the separation of the North and the South as the beginning of our national history. And there was that Burgundian golden age before. And it was that golden age that created the low countries who split it up afterwards. And then the other question, is it about Belgium? Yes, does it influence Belgium? They didn't create Belgium. but without the Burgundian
我认为这也许解释了我的书在我们国家成功的原因，因为我们把它遗忘了。因为出于民族叙事的原因——我不知道你在英国是否有这个概念：民族叙事、民族历史、民族故事。是的，我们把南北的分裂作为我们民族历史的开端。而在那之前，有一个勃艮第的黄金时代。正是那个黄金时代创造了后来分裂的低地国家。然后另一个问题，关于比利时？是的，它影响了比利时吗？它们没有创造比利时。但如果没有勃艮第
dukes, we never could have invented Belgium in 1830. And it had a lot more to do with Europe, I think. Because we have to imagine Philip the Bold in his fairytale palace in Brussels with a big bag, and in that bag
公爵，我们在1830年绝不可能发明出比利时。而且它与欧洲有更多的关系，我认为。因为我们必须想象大胆的菲利普带着一个大袋子坐在他布鲁塞尔的童话宫殿里，在那个袋子里装着
all those countries and all those duchies and counties that he conquered those countries he and all those duchies and counties that he did he conquered and he really really fastly he was aware of the fact that it it's when you put a lot of countries in one bag you don't create automatically a sense of unity i should just should whisper one name europe it's a european problem avant latre. And he's dealing with it like Europe has done it and has to do it again by reforming on a jurisdictional level, monetary. He creates a euro avant la lettre, a monetary union. I always say the monetary union. Monetary union.
所有那些国家、所有那些他征服的公国和伯爵领——那些国家，他以及所有那些他征服的公国和伯爵领，他非常、非常迅速地意识到这样一个事实：当你把许多国家装进一个袋子里时，你并不会自动创造出一种团结感。我应该只轻声说出一个名字：欧洲。这是个“超前”的欧洲问题（un problème européen avant l'heure）。他正在处理它，就像欧洲曾经做过的那样，并且不得不再次通过在司法、货币层面上进行改革来处理它。他创造了一个先于时代的欧元（euro avant la lettre），一个货币联盟。我总是说货币联盟。货币联盟。
So that is very interesting. We see a kind of, yes, it's a kind of European way of sorting out problems. But quick question, interruption. So the implication of what you're saying is that Burgundy, he's trying to create an artificial state. Yes, it is. So does that make it inevitable that it will fail, do you think? I don't know. In the beginning, England was also an artificial state.
所以这非常有趣。我们看到了一种，是的，这是一种欧洲式的解决问题的方法。但有个快问，打断一下。所以你的话暗示了勃艮第在试图创造一个人造国家。是的，它是。那么这是否意味着它的失败是不可避免的，你觉得呢？我不知道。一开始，英国也是一个人造国家。
You get to fight to put different people together who didn't want to belong together. It was in Germany. It was in Italy and Germany. It lasted for more than 1,000 years before they really got together. So all states are in some way artificial. Only when they lasted long enough, it becomes like it's natural. Okay, so I think the last question
你必须通过战斗把不同的人群捏合在一起，而他们并不想聚在一起。德国也是如此。意大利和德国也是。它们持续了1000多年才真正结合在一起。所以所有的国家在某种程度上都是人造的。只有当它们存在足够长的时间后，它才会变得像自然的一样。好吧，所以我想最后一个问题，
before we finish is from Denver Brito, who just asked, do you think Burgundy had a real shot at becoming independent? If Charles had been less bold, if Louis had been less of a spider, if the ever-acquisitive Habsburgs hadn't managed to acquire
在我们结束之前，来自丹佛·布里托，他只是问：你认为勃艮第真的有机会变得独立吗？如果查尔斯不那么鲁莽，如果路易不那么像个蜘蛛，如果贪婪成性的哈布斯堡家族没有设法获得
the Burgundian inheritance, could things have gone the other way? Could you literally now be a Burgundian? Oh, yes, I am. I am a Burgundian? Oh, yes, I am. I am a Burgundian. I feel Belgian, Flemish, Brabant, Holland. I'm married to a French woman who was born in Burgundy. I'm a Melange.
勃艮第的遗产，事情会不会走向另一个方向？你现在真的能成为一个勃艮第人吗？哦，是的，我是。我是勃艮第人吗？哦，是的，我是。我是勃艮第人。我感到自己是比利时人、弗拉芒人、布拉班特人、荷兰人。我娶了一个出生在勃艮第的法国女人。我是一个大杂烩（mélange）。
I'm a Burgundian Melange and I'm proud of it. But yes, that's counterfactual history. What if not to mention the name Uchrony? And of course, we all could dream about that middle Reich. No, no, middle Reich, that's so German. That middle empire in Europe between France and Germany, a country where they speak Dutch, where they speak German, where they speak French.
我是一个勃艮第大杂烩，我为此感到自豪。但是是的，那是反事实历史。如果不是，更不用说“虚构历史”（Uchrony）这个词了。当然，我们都可以梦想那个中间帝国。不，不，中间帝国，那太德国了。欧洲法德之间那个中间帝国，一个他们说荷兰语、说德语、说法语的国家。
They would have a shot if Charles de Boel was, if he would have made some boys, if he would be as patient as his father. But that's so difficult to predict. Do you regret it then? Are you sad? Every Sunday morning a bit. I regret it. But we mustn't face history with regret.
如果鲁莽的查尔斯是……如果他生了几个男孩，如果他能像他父亲那样有耐心，他们本会有机会的。但这太难预测了。那你为此感到后悔吗？你难过吗？每个星期天早晨会有一点。我感到遗憾。但我们不能带着遗憾去看待历史。
I think that's not a good way to look at it. But every Sunday morning a bit, I do. I should say that I'm very, very... Such a sad note on which to end. Yes, because the Burgundians almost invaded England. It was Philip the Bold. He parted from the Flemish town of Slas in 1386. And it's among the most spectacular pages in my book.
我认为这不是看待它的好方法。但每个星期天早晨，我确实会有一点。我应该说我非常、非常……这是一个多么悲伤的结束语啊。是的，因为勃艮第人差点入侵英国。那是大胆的菲利普。他于1386年从法兰德斯小镇斯勒斯（Sluis）出发。这是我书中最为壮观的篇章之一。
And though impressive and spectacular, it's a failed invasion. But I'm so glad that 635 years after the failed Burgundian invasion of England, the Burgundians finally crossed the Channel. And I should say you better keep a good watch on those dukes. But before you know, they will take over the whole country. Well, a terrifying note on which to end. A warning. end. A warning from across the sea. Bart, thanks so much.
尽管宏伟壮观，但那是一次失败的入侵。但我很高兴，在勃艮第人兵败英国635年之后，勃艮第人终于跨越了海峡。我得说，你们最好看好那些公爵。不然在你意识到之前，他们就要占领整个国家了。好吧，这是一个令人毛骨悚然的结束语。来自海峡对岸的警告。巴特，非常感谢。
That was an absolute torture force. And it's a brilliant book, your book, The Burgundians, A Vanished Empire History. A great Christmas present if you're looking for Christmas presents for people who are interested in history. And I think also, you know, it would hugely encourage you to diversify your Christmas feast, wouldn't it
这是一次绝对的杰作之旅。这是一本好书，你的书《勃艮第人：一个消失帝国的历史》（The Burgundians, A Vanished Empire History）。如果你在为对历史感兴趣的人寻找圣诞礼物，这会是一份很棒的圣诞礼物。我想这也是，你知道的，它会极大地鼓励你在圣诞大餐上进行创新，不是吗？
it would yes full of great great cooking ideas yes a good banquet rabbits with cats heads and all kinds of mad stuff hungarian dwarfs yes yeah and dwarfs of course what's a christmas feast without a dwarf um so but thanks so much uh and uh thanks everyone for listening and um we will be back next week for two very, very festive shows. We'll see you then. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening,
是的，充满了伟大的烹饪创意。是的，一场好的宴会，带着猫头的兔子和各种疯狂的东西，匈牙利侏儒，是的，还有侏儒，当然，没有侏儒的圣诞大餐算什么圣诞大餐呢，嗯——所以，非常感谢，呃，谢谢大家的收听，呃，我们下周会带着两个非常、非常具有节日气氛的节目回归。到时候见。拜拜。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取独家单集、提前收听、无广告收听
and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及访问我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。